I heard I have been getting a sense of
the order in which I've done things do
you remember we looked at basic
identities basic equations then I showed
you the T results okay and then I showed
you T results with the identities and
identities with that right so you can
compare the same thing today
now we're gonna bless you we're gonna
start very simple examples and today I'm
gonna hopefully bring out what that
problem with the team results was okay
so we're going to do questions both ways
like with T results and then solving it
the way that you normally would without
I'm going to choose simple examples ones
that you can equally do both ways so
that you don't get bogged down in how
difficult the question is I can see the
concept at work okay so let's start with
a super super easy one and we'll go from
I don't care so coz x equals zero now I
ran can hopefully fingers crossed
because it's such a simple question you
might even be able to just write down
the answer there are two solutions and
maybe you know the shape of the cosine
curve well enough to be like our
solution their solution there we are
going to do that ii just file it away in
the back of your head
let's do with this by t results first
let's see how it works okay so if you
want to look at a question it's got no
T's in everything you have to introduce
the t's okay so the first thing you say
is met T equals T cool
excellent okay now do you remember that
identity I showed you before it didn't
actually make sense to make it 10 X into
sometimes just an X sometimes it may be
10 2x or 3x it just depends on what kind
of question you've got okay but this is
kind of default way that you start if
that's T then you can go straight to say
well therefore cos x ought to be equal
to and they try to remember the T result
okay if you struggle a little bit
drawing triangles okay
but hopefully most of you know by now
it's 1 minus on 1 plus okay so that's
just the standard - all right now
therefore this one's really simple I
don't need to bring in any other ones
any other set up so I just take that and
I say well that's equal to 0 now you can
see in this case I can disregard the
denominator okay because there's no
value that the denominator can take that
makes the whole thing zebra so another
way of thinking about that is I can just
multiply through by 1 plus T Square they
don't get this okay no that has two
solutions plus or minus 1 so that means
tierd of X onto has two solutions
plus the latest one okay I probably
should have knowed it by the way I was a
bit sloppy with this because I've noted
this domain in the beginning the second
you turn into T's right you don't have
excess anymore your ex on to so that's
going to adjust your domain a little bit
if this is in Exodus and I want to talk
in terms of X on twos
I'm going to take that and I'm going to
divide by two so seeing that I've
divided that part of the inequality by 2
I divide every other part right
so my new domain for these T results
will be between 0 and pi okay all right
yeah come down to here let's branch this
off a little bit turn of X 1/2 we'll
start with the easy one first for that
equal to 1 okay now what value of 2
sorry what value of x or 2 if you take
his head of that gives you 1 that's an
exact value
do you remember ingredients 10 of what
gives you 1 pi and 4 right so that means
that X on - he's paying for ok now you
look at that your check is it in the
domain no problems okay are there any
other solutions to this in the domain No
so you move on okay no I actually want
next so I'm multiplying through by 2
tada there's one solution now I'll do
the other one it might be a little less
familiar with that so maybe think back
to either your graph or your quadrants
right so maybe in this case come bit of
a fan of graphs I'll do coordinates just
for the sake of it okay so PI over 4 is
my base angle right when I come around
to here no sorry yeah 10 is negative
right so which quadrant in my after
actually answered this one so X on 2 is
going to be 3 PI on four you can verify
that chuckling attack
okay to plan for is in this quadrant
that's why it's negative x a2 and there
are your two answers do we plan to now
let's just confirm that you don't have
to do this obviously when you're doing
this properly as a question but just for
us since we're introducing a certain
idea let's go back to cos x equals zero
how would you solve this without T
results pretty simple I would graph it
Carlos X in this domain looks like so
okay and there's your midpoint at pine
it ends at 2pi okay so causes is equal
to zero I'm looking for these of
intercepts here right and just by the
symmetry of it you can see that's odd to
write in the same way